darcos bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes le ministre de
l'éducation
et comme tous les ministres vous êtes
priés d'avoir des idées pour la période
qui s'ouvre et qui est celle de la
présidence de l'union européenne à la
présidence dont il faut pas faire une
montagne non plus mais néanmoins
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui va être
prioritaires pour vous dans le domaine
de l'éducation vis-à-vis de vos
collègues ministres que vous allez
tenter de guider et vers quoi
d'abord il faut dire que les ans a pris
cette présidence très au sérieux au
ministre indications national parce que
nous avons conscience que l'eau des
moyens de faire d'europe c'est de rendre
évident cet espace pour les populations
qui vont venir aux affaires et que pour
les jeunes ça va de soi alors donc nous
avons beaucoup pensé à elle et je vais y
revenir à ces jeunes populations
mais il ya trois aspects il ya l'aspect
institutionnel nous sommes beaucoup vus
entre ministres et nous avons choisi
ensemble les thèmes qui nous serait
commun pour cette période et nous avons
choisi comme thème principal
l'orientation il ya d'autres sujets il
ya l'accueil des handicapés la gestion
des établissements d'enseignement
précoce des sciences mais fondamentaux
par l'orientation l'orientation tout au
long de la vie et ce sont ces sujets là
qui vont nous occuper
thématiquement entre ministres
éducationnel de des divers pays
nous nous verrons il y aura un grand
colloque à lyon au mois de septembre et
puis il y aura à la fin du mois de
novembre une réunion informelle de tous
les ministres de ce sujet qu'est-ce qui
est ce qui peut l'être
imaginez que votre présidence à vous
dans l'éducation soit réussie qu'est-ce
qui peut naître sur l'orientation ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire une sport ce
soir de dison la définition de principes
communs ou et ancien chirurgien surtout
c'est à faire en sorte que nous ayons
déco validation et des politiques qui se
ressemblent qui permettent à
jeune homme de circuler dans l'espace
européen et ce qu'il a commencé ici toi
contenir ailleurs et l'orientation c'est
évidemment l'orientation tout au long de
la vie c'est l'orientation précoce qui a
très tôt au mieux connaître les métiers
me connaître comment on peut construire
sa vie professionnelle mais c'est aussi
pour voir se renouveler à ensuite et
donc il faut que nous ayons un système
de d'équivalence un système de
reconnaissance mutuelle des expériences
professionnelles système qu'ils appelent
aux helvètes qui permet de valider des
acquis professionnels
c'était d'ailleurs le deuxième aspect à
côté de l'aspect institutionnel il ya
l'aspect fonctionnel
comment faire en sorte que l'espace
européenne devienne un espace unique
d'éducation que nous reconnaissions
mutuellement nos diplômes que lorsqu'on
passe un bac à la rue en france il soit
reconnu en allemagne ou en bulgarie et
que lorsque nous proposons des
formations professionnelles ou temps de
la vie elle puisse être validé et puis
le troisième aspect c'est le plus
important suit la suite
enfin les urbains gars c'est le plus
important c'est le pont de l'île
nous avons pensé aux jeunes et nous
avons eu cette idée de faire des cahiers
de vacances pour les jeunes élèves trois
cahiers selon les âges 6 9 en un an et
un peu plus tard
et puis de ses 15 ans presque quinze ans
oui qui sont qui sont très ludiques en
fait ils sont très bien faits dateraient
lui dit l'idée est faire quelque chose
de jeunes de fred amusant mais qui en
même temps sur des cahiers de vacances
vraiment voulu faire des mathématiques
de la physique je ne sais quoi de la
géométrie haut de l'histoire
mais surtout on peut découvrir au fur et
à mesure que l'on avance dans des
cahiers de vacances on découvre les pays
puisque chaque chapitre est en fait un
pays à 27 chapitres et chaque fois on
rencontre un des pays de l'europe
et puis une explication des institutions
européennes je vous demande s'il
faudrait pas parce que ces 13 15 ans
mais ça pourrait être même dit aux
symboles et qui s'étend sur 17 ans a
pour laquelle peser lui aussi pour qui
les appréhende un peu mieux cette chez
les tout petits on essaie de leur faire
comprendre en gros sur les pays
quelles sont leurs leur capital tout
petit peu de repères comme ça
pittoresque le deuxième on passe un peu
au stade au dessus cette hargne on
commence à parler de leurs spécificités
on dit quelque chose de leur histoire de
leurs coutumes leur mode de vie
et puis le dernier est évidemment
beaucoup plus tournée vers l'espace
situationnelle comment s'organisera tel
ou tel pays dans le contexte européenne
au volant l'école étant finie comment
sont ils accessibles ces cahiers ils
sont accessibles sur le net évidemment
ils sont accessibles nous les avons dit
si l'on entend que cai et oui nous les
distribuons gratuitement à tous les
élèves qui sont encore plus ou moins
liés à nos soit qu'ils soient dans des
réseaux ambition réussite soit qu'il
soit en train de faire des stages de
remédiation début d'année soit qu'ils
s'entendent école ouverte où nous les
distribuons si on fait un numéro il
verrait on dit voilà je suis monsieur
untel et je veux envoyer d'un grand
sport aux enfants on les envoie
gratuitement où on peut les télécharger
les imprimés sur à partir d'un site qui
s'appelle mon cahier d'europe point
education.gouv.fr normes et moments clés
d'europe sur n'importe quel voilà
système de recherche on ne trouvera ou
enfin on peut tout simplement le faire
sur écran à dire au lieu de deux privés
de cahiers on a des pages qui
apparaissent et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant c'est interactif et à la
correction qui est fait sur l'écran et
donc je pense que c'est plutôt cette
manière là qui sera la plus utilisée en
tout cas ils sont très bien fait une
dernière question sur sur l'europe il ya
très longtemps
l'idée était parce que on a un problème
de langue on a un problème par exemple
en italie
les professeurs de français sont
remerciés ou mis à la retraite ou
remercier parce qu'il ya plus d'élèves
en espagne on a bien vu à quel point le
français recule et c'est donc est ce que
il y avait une idée à un moment il ya
quelques années qui était de dire mais
il faudrait sur le territoire de l'union
rendre obligatoire l'enseignement de
deux langues vivantes parce que tout le
monde sait bien que partout sur la
planète dont dans l'union réellement on
apprend l'anglais tout le tous les
enfants apprennent l'anglais
donc si on dit une deuxième langue est
obligatoire on va réhabiliter le
français
en espagne en italie en allemagne on va
réhabiliter l'allemand en france ainsi
de suite
est-ce que ça c'est en seulement
envisageable ou est-ce que c'est
totalement utopique mais non seulement
c'est envisageable mais ça fait partie
des projets que nous avons en commun il
ya un commissaire européen qui
chargeaient du bilinguisme quand vous
savez sans d'autres qui s'occupent de
cette question exclusivement et donc
nous avons nous faisant montée en charge
du dispositif qui fait qu'un parti de la
classe 6e on puisse avoir deux langues
vivantes est entendu que presque tous
nos jeunes élèves qui font danser non
précoce des langues vivantes c'est à
dire tout le monde est presque tous
choisissent l'anglais donc ils ont
commencé l'anglais généralement on sait
qu'ils ont quand même quelques
connaissances dans le lait peuvent
poursuivre plus facilement
c'est vrai que la france est un peu à la
traîne de ce point de vue là je crois
pas que cette semaine seulement à nos
méthodes ça tient à notre histoire
personnelle dont nous nous avons
beaucoup plus de mal que d autres à nous
y mettre l'huile avant lorsque des fans
chinois ou lorsqu'on est hollandais ou
slovène
il vaut mieux parler l'anglais parce que
on a peu de chance de rencontrer souvent
quelqu'un qui parle votre langue native
donc ça va de soi nous les français nous
étions habitués à cette illusion que
l'on finirait toujours par se
débrouiller ont jeté moins en moins vrai
voulait de le dire
le français recule partout et donc n'ont
jamais il faut qu'il faut il faut que
nous ayons d une formation bilingue mais
comme vous l'indiquez il faut que nos
pays partenaires et des formations binet
que c'est une chance pour le français
donc il faudrait peut-être inscrire sa
aussi dans votre objectif de 100 fait
partie je les ai pas tous évoqués mais
parmi l'une des thématiques nous avons
été en effet bilal ou alors sur le front
national l'année est terminée l'année
terminée vous êtes toujours là c'est
toujours une surprise d'ailleurs en fin
d'année pour sa techno médicaux
il est toujours là des mouvements divers
et variés sur ce secteur votre action au
fond elle a quand même été très
largement obscurci donc on ira peut-être
un petit peu de ce que vous avez tenté
au long de l'année a été obscurcie par
la question des chiffres et du non
renouvellement du nom non renouvellement
de ceux qui partent à la retraite donc
de la non de diminutions de postes est
bon il ya une bataille là dessus
peut-être l'épreuve du feu sera t-elle à
la rentrée pour vous quand les gens
constateront à la réduction des postes
et on dit que ça n'est pas terminé alors
où en sommes nous à la fois les tops
securties part cela parce que devenue un
slogan comme par hasard par des plus que
de ça mais aussi elle a été légitimée
par ça parce que moi je crois
profondément d'une part qu'il était
nécessaire que le fassions efforts en
matière d'emploi public en france il
n'ya pas de doute nous avons énormément
de fonctionnaires qui est très important
et d'autre part c'est une manière pour
nous de nous poser les vraies questions
chaque fois que l'éducation nationale
rencontre une difficulté des mouvements
des moments d'humeur y compris ils ont
rajouté des postes comment se
débrouiller le résultat quand ce qu'on
fait le bilan de tout ça c'est qu'on ait
fait nous avons beaucoup de
fonctionnaires que notre encadrement
pédagogique est un des meilleurs du
monde que tout le tout tout cela va
assez bien avec une résultats ne sont
pas du tout satisfaisant et donc ça
montre bien que la quantité n'a pas
résolu la question de la qualité et en
particulier c'est très frappant dans le
land premier degré où nous avons un
encadrement pédagogique nombreux quelle
bonne qualité nous avons des réseaux
d'adam fin à beaucoup de monde et en
même temps nos résultats sont fragiles
ne sont pas bien placés
lorsqu'on ne se compare avec les pays
comparables et non seulement nous sommes
ne peuvent pas bien placé mais nous
avons perdu nous avons régressé très
sensiblement en une vingtaine d'années
de manière perceptible c'est pas du tout
un fantasme sur des choses élémentaires
que son parti que la compréhension de la
langue la maîtrise du discours aussi
bien du discours littéraire que discours
mathématiques et donc en remettant
l'accent sur ce point là ce n'est pas du
tout pour être réactionnaire comme on
dit au bout je ne sais quoi c'est tout
savoir parce que il faut que nous
reconquerrons y ont une place dans ce
dans ces classements tout simplement
parce que quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
langue
il n'a rien dit non plus le français
c'est pas une discipline c'est celle qui
permet d'accéder en voit revenir sur les
chiffres mais ça c'est l'aspect retour
j'allais dire aux fondamentaux des
questions partant du fait que raymond
peu d'enfants et c'est qu'on connaisse
ces bases là et vous avez été très
vertement d'un durement tancé par deux
de vos prédécesseurs
luc ferry plutôt à droite et jacques
lang plutôt à gauche
néanmoins si vous avez au départ plutôt
bien accueillis alors comment nos
relations personnelles ne sont pas
mauvaises pour autant et en particulier
du ferry de est revenu ensuite puisque
j'ai tenu compte d'une partie des
critiques qui ne m'avait exposé sur la
première mouture des profs du primaire
et depuis là il sait il sert rallier si
je puis dire un nouveau programme
bon on sait conscient jack lang il y
avait évidemment un peu de tactique dans
tout ça c'est de la politique aussi j'ai
eu beaucoup de mal à comprendre le
procès qu'on faisait au nouveau
programme
non seulement parce qu'ils correspondent
à ce que tous les pays modernes ont fait
revenir à des éléments clairs simples
lisibles et transparent dans des enfants
en a vraiment besoin pour se construire
ensuite la liberté ce n'est pas son
point de départ c'est un point d'arrivée
il faut quand même il faut quand même
construire décemment et d'autre part
aussi parce que ces programmes tels que
nous avions peut rédiger c'est à dire
une inspection générale les avait rédigé
ils ont été soumis à une très vaste
consultation ont dit qu'ils ont été
imposées mais c'est une blague
tous les professeurs du premier degré
sans exception 360 milles s'il vous
plaît maison quand même lui il ya eu
ensuite 11000 synthèse par
circonscription de l'éducation nationale
nous avons consulté les deux assemblées
le sénat et l'éducation et le sens à
l'assemblée nationale qui nous ont donné
leur avis par des commissions
spécialisées nous avons consulté les
académies le haut conseil pour l'école
qui n'a pas été créée par mois où je
n'ai pas nommé les personnes ce n'est
pas moi qui les fais il a donné un avis
favorable à l'unanimité
il ya de l'eau au conseil par les
cendres des professeurs au collège de
france alors qu'on me dit quand on
présente comme une espèce de l'uby qu'un
beau matin monsieur darcos ce soit via
dit tiens je remettais tout le monde à
faire de vos programmes
c'est une blague présente surtout comme
un comme un élément de d'un programme
idéologique puisque tout ça étaient
environnés d'un discours sur au fond les
dérives
et à mai 68 les nouvelles pédagogies etc
mais moi je vais vous parler je n'en a
pas que ça c'est dans ce contexte là
mais moi je ne me préoccupe pas de
reprendre des revanches avec qui que ce
soit je ne sais pas du tout comme ça je
suis j'essaie de voir ce qui me paraît
le plus utile face à la difficulté que
notre aujourd'hui qui est que 15 % nos
élèves arrivent en sixième est
absolument incapable de dire est que ces
15% là il s'en sociologiquement
extrêmement marqué un
un fils de cadres supérieurs il a une
chance de plus une fois plus de chances
que un fils d'ouvrier de savoir lire
entre en 6e tout ça ne va pas donc on
peut me dire ce qu'on voudra sur le fait
que c'était idéal avant je ne le crois
pas cette réforme était nécessaire
ce n'est pas du tout une réforme imposée
duo brutale est dictée par des revanches
ou par une idéologie est particulière
c'est tout ce que la plus pragmatique
nous essayons de faire en sorte que les
petits français aillent mieux à l'école
primaire
alors peut être que ça passerait mieux
si on n'était pas dans ce concept dans
ce contexte pardon de réduction ou
l'exercer vous avez raison et donc
localement ça peut être d'ailleurs très
durement ressentie parce que ça se
traduit par les fermetures de classes
world et fermetures d'école ou de
collège enfin est donc en même temps on
dit encore une fois c'est pas fini donc
comment abordez vous les voyez javari
qui ont madani sy comme un homme si bien
d'affirmer que vous pourtant dit des
choses que qui ne sont pas tout à fait
exact d'abord nous ne fermons aucune
classe du premier degré nous avons des
regroupements de classes comme il se
faisait chaque année et nous l'avons
retiré aucun emploi dans le premier
degré nous en rajoute dans la rentrée
prochaine 820 tout le monde est
convaincu que nous en retirons alors
nous n'avons pas touché au premier degré
précisément parce que nous voulions
sauvegarder cet enfant du premier degré
les post porte exclusivement sur le
second degré et il s'agit de onze mille
deux cents postes 11500 et nous en avons
converti cinq milliards supplémentaires
une partie concerne deux de
l'administration donc finalement les
professeurs stricto sensu qui ne sont
pas renouvelés sont peu nombreux 3500 et
ça se fait dans un contexte nous perdons
régulièrement des élèves nous avons
perdu l'an dans les 45000 enel dans le
second degré donc tout ceci est
parfaitement gérable et vous n'aurez pas
une classe où il y avait un professeur
qui faisait son cours à la rentrée il
serait plus là c'est de la blague tout
ça ça n'existe pas vous n'aurez pas une
classe où ils étaient 20 ou à devenir 45
ce n'est pas vrai
pas de palais de classe à plus de 40 en
france mais ça a été un combat
idéologique était conduit contre la
droite en la présentant comme l'ennemi
de l'école vouloir faire des économies
sur l'école mais moi je n'ai aucun état
d'âme à partir du moment où cette cette
situation tendue m'oblige à me réformer
et à part du moment aussi ça me dispense
demain dans le cahier des écoliers la
dette qu'il paiera un jour parce qu'on
peut pas faire comme si ce problème de
l'emprunt public n'existait pas et comme
si c'était une sorte de 2,2 de droits de
tirages sans fin que nous avions sur
l'impôt des contribuables ce qu'il faut
plutôt chine nouvelle forme et voyez par
exemple on me dit vous retirer des
postes dans le second degré oui mais
j'ai organisé des scolaires aussi je
vais par exemple qu'on travaille au mois
de juin ce qu'on ne faisait plus depuis
bien longtemps travaillé au mois de juin
pour tout le monde alors que de la
sixième à la terminale un terminal
pratiquement un mois étaient perdus
chaque année ces six sept mois de gagnés
c'est pratiquement les scolaires or une
semaine de lycée ça coûte 250 millions
d'euros
donc ça vaut la peine peut être que ces
semaines aient lieu voilà il faut
réformer du dedans plutôt que croire qu
ajouter des couches d'enseignants se
réglera tous les problèmes
alors ya quand même un problème moi qui
me perturbe beaucoup qui est le landais
classement au fond des professions
intellectuelles
vous avez raison en général et donc des
enseignants en particulier et on se dit
si l'état fait un effort alors je sais
bien qu'il ya le contexte de la dépense
publique qui est assez compliquée mais
néanmoins si l'état fait un effort en
terme d'effectif très bien il ya moins
d'effectifs mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas
moyen de revaloriser mais de le
revaloriser de façon significative
sensible c'est l'histoire du salaire de
départ des jeunes enseignants qui sont
quand même qui montre en eux mêmes ce
sont des salaires trop faibles et d'anti
qui montrent que le regard de la société
sur ses personnels n'est pas à la
hauteur de la tente ensuite qui est de
la cette même société vis-à-vis de ses
personnels enseignants et donc on
comprend que les personnels enseignants
petit à petit ressentent comme une sorte
de paupérisation de leur métier et donc
ça ne peut pas là le pays ne peut pas
fonctionner sur ces bases là voilà un
point d'accord absolue entre nous
j'aimerais qu'on me dit je suis tout à
fait de votre avis je suis là est
d'ailleurs tellement votre avis que ça
fait partie du programme politique du
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy qui a dit on est en effet il
faut tel que celui en moins nombreux
mais il faut
valoriser le métier d'enseignant léger
mission de le faire il avance et
compliqué parce qu'ils sont très
nombreux et qu'ils appartiennent tous au
corps au chaos khadra donc sa produira
de l'effet par rapport à d'autres
ministères mais nous allons le faire
voilà pourquoi nous voulons masteriser
des concours sadi recruteurs un tout
petit peu plus tard avec une formation
d'un an de plus et ce qui permettra dé
recruter plus tard de faire des débuts
de carrière meilleur mais d'une manière
générale les professeurs en france sont
pas assez payés ne sont pas assez
considéré leur début de carrière est
presque humiliant ils sont tombés dans
des postes extrêmement difficile avec
1,3 après on fait très bonnes études et
nous ne savons pas nous n'avons pas su
jusqu'ici revaloriser sur le plan
matériel comme seul tort moral
elle cette fonction je m'y engage mais
il faut aussi que les professeurs de
leur côté face un petit effort et en
particulier il faudrait que une partie
de ceux qui sont dans le mouvement dans
les mouvements de contestation commente
pas des syndicats qui sont généralement
très responsable mais tout ceci
coordination qui font tout pour
accréditer l'image d'un d'enseignants
jamais content extrêmement enfermés dans
des une vision très gauchiste du
mouvement en organisant des
protestations ridicule ou dérisoire de
manière systématique il faut aussi que
que les professeurs n'accréditent pas
l'idée de cette immaturité
je ne parle pas des professeurs en
général je ne parle pas des syndicats en
général je parle de ceux qui continuent
parfois à faire des coordinations des
moments ici ou là qu'occupe aux échos
qui ont accouché îles sandwich est que
celle où est installé leur tente il y en
a une espèce de deux manières de
ridiculiser au fond la dignité de de la
revendication à laquelle il faut prendre
garde parce que les français ne sont pas
dupes de tout ça et qu'est-ce qu'ils
font pendant ce temps là lorsqu'ils
voient une école comme ça occupe et
agité qu'est ce qu'ils font et vivent
dans l'école pu priver c'est ce qui se
passe partout et donc ce n'est pas la
meilleure façon de défendre l'école
publique alors un mot pour terminer et
xavier darcos un de vos prédécesseurs
claude allègre qui s'était rendu célèbre
par son impopularité vis-à-vis des
personnels enseignants et parce qu'il
avait au fond des dents dénoncé l'énorme
machinerie qu'est l'éducation nationale
vous êtes un homme de l'intérieur de la
machine vous êtes professeur vous
connaissez tout ça de l'intérieur est ce
que ça reste est-ce que c'est gérable de
fait
est-ce que c'est gérable est ce que ces
réformes à blaye ce que l'outil en effet
n'est pas trop lourd est ce que le
moment n'est pas ne serait pas venue
d'une d'une franche décentralisation
enfin je sais que vous pose une question
à rallonge mais a tué qu'est ce qu'il
faut c'est nommer votre fils de feu dans
l'établissement il faut que je domine
les établissements réagissent plus par
romaine qui s'adapte au terrain qu'ils
aient que le chef d'établissement c'est
une personnalité très forte un vrai chef
d'equipe qu'ils puissent un peut agir
sur ces personnels qui puisse à la marge
brute et des personnes ressources en
chine aura besoin qu'ils puissent se
fixer des stratégies un projet
établissements et donc non pas que tout
vienne d'en haut
c'est d'ailleurs de plus en plus le cas
mais la confiance au terrain est sans
aucun doute d'une bonne une des réponses
que nous vous devons avoir vis-à-vis
dicale sociale qui reste une machine
extrêmement lourdes et commander un très
rétive qui voit toujours dans toutes les
réformes une menace alors que qu'est ce
qui dit que l'action d'un ministre tous
les matins c'est pal a envie de faire la
paix nogent mois ce qui conduit mon
action matin et soir depuis toujours
d'ailleurs depuis que je m'occupe des
coyotes qu'est ce qui me semble être de
bonne foi dans l'intérêt des enfants
sachant qu'ils échangent me pose est
donc peut-être arrivé à accorder un peu
de crédit à ceux qui s'occupent des cols
et accepter un peu de souplesse
d'évolution il ya encore beaucoup à
faire pour cela beaucoup de pédagogie du
ministre vis-à-vis de sa propre maison
merci beaucoup d'années darcos est en
tout cas pour la pédagogie des enfants
vis-à-vis de l'europe yade nos cahiers
d'europe mon cahier d'europe long qui
sont disponibles pour une société libre
et pour tous les âges
merci xavier c'est moi qui vous remercie
jean françois copé bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
des députés ump à l'assemblée nationale
et vous avez beaucoup de choses sur
votre plan de charge on va en parler un
petit peu on va sélectionner un peu les
sujets mais d'abord la télévision parce
que la télévision ça a été la grande
affaire et c'est toujours la grande
affaire et le grand débat le grand sujet
de débat donc réforme de la télévision
publique mais tout ça a été éclipsée
complètement par le fait que l'exécutif
reprend en main c'est dans tout cas ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
la nomination du patron de france
télévisions donc tollé général et
inquiétude à juste titre à ce que ce
n'est pas un retour en arrière au tour à
l'eau et rtf folie totale et c'est alors
sûrement dire un mot de cela avant de
parler un petit peu aussi de ce qu'il y
a derrière toute cette réforme jean
françois copé d'abord je crois que ça
c'est très français on adore samba
s'emballer dans des débats polémiques
sur ce sujet de la nomination du
président de france télé il ya quand
même une cohérence que d'ailleurs
nicolas sarkozy à assumer clairement se
sortir de l'hypocrisie après tout c'est
une entreprise publique de l'état à 100%
c'est pas aberrant qui nomme le
président de cette entreprise a dès lors
qu'il respecte les conditions qu'il a
évoquée c'est à dire qu'il faut un avis
conforme du csa premier verrou et une
majorité qualifiée des trois cinquièmes
du parlement deuxième verrou dont c'est
dire quand même que sur ces sujets il ya
quand même une garantie de pluralisme et
puis je voudrais dire moi aussi comme
vous d'ailleurs que je vous rejoins
c'est que du coup cette polémique un peu
occulté le fond du rapport parce que ce
que nous avons bâti au sein de notre
commission en réalité c'est un projet
fantastique pour la télé publique de
demain c'est sans nous je crois le
meilleur chemin pour permettre d'avoir
un grand groupe de télévision public
demain qui je pense sera un modèle pour
l'europe
alors on va y venir mais juste un mot
sur ce deuxième verrou qui dépend en
même temps de la réforme
constitutionnelle etc
mais c'est vrai que c'est passé inaperçu
mais de fait c'est quand même
l'opposition aurait un droit de regard
de fait sur le président du conseil
vallières oui on faisait exactement mais
non mais c'est très lent cesser
complètement occulté par
mais parce qu'il ya une c'est un sujet
moi j'ai bien vu ça fait pendant cinq
mois j'ai animé les travaux de cette
commission j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
professionnels naturellement du milieu
du visuel en réalité c'est un milieu qui
est hyper réactif qui sur le moindre
sujet ça donne lieu immédiatement un
débat polémique dramaturgie alors de ce
qui est vrai c'est qu'il faut essayer de
répondre point par point et
méthodiquement à tout cela c'est ce que
je m'efforce de faire et y compris grâce
à vous voilà en même temps simplement
c'est vrai qu'on était parti d'une
situation vous en souvenez peut-être pas
comme bon mais ni moi non plus
d'ailleurs mais c'était alain peyrefitte
qui est à venise de la formation donc au
fond la télévision publique et être un
élément de l'administration puis progrès
successifs on a considéré que
l'introduction de la haute autorité
puisse cncl puis csa était autant de
progrès vers au fond une émancipation et
là au fond nicolas sarkozy dit je suis
l'actionnaire majoritaire principal et
donc c'est moi qui nomme henri maurin
voter il faut quand même relativiser
tout ça personne ne compense une seconde
que la nomination d'un président de
france télévisions va donner une
orientation éditoriale à une chaîne ce
qu'on attend du président de france télé
c'est que ce soit un développeur pour un
groupe public qui a besoin maintenant se
réorganiser de devenir une entreprise
unique plutôt que cette constellation de
49 sociétés dispersé que ce soit un
média global plutôt que d'être un
système dans lequel on vit chacun chez
soi sans connecter avec les autres
chaînes que on y associer internet qu'on
ait un développement commercial qu'on
ait une programmation qu'on trouve nulle
part ailleurs tout autant de sujets qui
n'ont rien et rock la politique
politicienne d'ailleurs cette idée que
parce que c'est un président est lui qui
nommerait faudrait forcément que ce soit
quelqu'un de son bord politique
moi je vous dit cette compo peut-être
nommer quelqu'un simplement parce qu'il
est compétent et en se fichant
totalement de savoir ce qu'ils votent
dans le dans l'isoloir peut-être qu'on
peut imaginer ça aussi alors sur sur le
fond vous a énuméré un peu tout ce qui
est à l'ordre du jour autour de vous il
y avait assez de professionnels et
notamment des producteurs on voit bien
que les producteurs sont en première
ligne on a presque eu le sentiment qu'au
fond il avait un petit peu la main sur
le contenu des bases c'est vrai c'est un
grand enjeu en même temps la production
est énorme
que commence justement avait où vous
avez vous placez le curseur d'abord
d'abord disons les choses cette
commission elle avait autant de
parlementaires que de professionnels
jusqu'au départ des socialistes
malheureusement parce que franchement
c'était bien dommage qu'il parte alors
qu'ils apportaient une vraie
contribution enfin peu importe il y
avait donc autant de parlementaires que
de professionnels deuxièmement au sein
des professionnels vous aviez des
auteurs vous aviez des producteurs
effectivement mais vous aviez en réalité
des gens de natures très différentes et
donc c'est vrai que chacun a apporté sa
contribution marcel rufo pédopsychiatre
bien connu et est membre de cette
commission
donc en réalité ce que nous avons voulu
faire c'est d'essayer d'imaginer une
nouvelle articulation entre tous les
acteurs du paysage audiovisuel moi je
vois bien un exemple la question
financière est beaucoup plus qu paie la
redevance par la redevance moi j'étais
depuis le début très hostile est ce
qu'on augmente à l'exception de
l'indexer sur l'inflation
on a trouvé une nouvelle formule parce
que le constat de base c'est que la télé
française et sous-financée qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs privé au public parce que le
tient pas le coup et que quelqu'un
veuille ou non et au delà des aides sur
un invraisemblable que j'ai mesuré
contre tf1 qu' disproportionnée la
réalité des choses c'est qu'il fallait
trouver un nouvel acteur pour financer
pour coproduire pour nouer des
partenariats
c'est tout l'intérêt d'associer les
fournisseurs d'accès et les téléphones
mobiles qui sont aujourd'hui des gens
qui diffusent de l'offre de l'image sans
rien payer donc on voit bien le décalage
deuxième illustration de sa ce qu'on a
fait sur les contenus hyper intéressant
ce qu'on a fait sur les contenus on
imagine demain qu'avec les nouveaux
horaires c'est france télé qui va
quelque part guider les soirées puisque
elle démarrera à 20h30 et la deuxième
partie de soirée vers 22 heures 22h15
donc à la clé de nouvelles émissions
comme on n'aura jamais vu dans le
domaine du développement durable de la
science de l'europe de la politique
c'est on va réécrire scénarisé le
théâtre la littérature la culture au feu
est tout à fait magnifique et font ce
que la commission a fait c'est à cahier
des charges
en tout cas c'est une belle maquette
pouy c'est une belle maquette voilà donc
c'est quelque chose qui va être une
formidable contrainte en même temps pour
les futurs dirigeants de france
télévision parce qu'ils vont avoir au
fonds d'aidé des lignes dans lesquelles
ils devront s'inscrire on va c'est aussi
une contrainte pour l'etat-actionnaire
c'est moi je bois un revers très sévère
sur l'état actionnaire de france télé
moi j'étais ministre du budget j'étais
donc le tuteur de cette maison que j'ai
beaucoup vu sous l'angle comptable je
dois quand même vous dire que l'état
actionnaire n'a jamais fait son travail
on n'a jamais surveillé le commune
l'application du code du contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens qui sur trois
ans alors que le poids le mandat du
président et sur cinq ans qui déjà rien
que ça et une dinguerie
enfin bon il ya beaucoup de choses à
revoir mais l'idée c'est que ce soit un
cahier des charges mais ils ont une
maquette global avec cette idée du média
global justement dans lequel on a en
colonne des pôles à constituer le pôle
information le pôle documentaire le pôle
fiction etc et en vertical en abscisse
les différentes chaînes france 2 la
chaîne fédératrice france 3 la chaîne
des régions france 4 la chaîne du risque
de la création 35 de l'information et de
l'investigation et puis internet qui
doit développer là aussi tout son champ
d'action l'enjeu d'internet est en effet
majeur mais est ce qu'on craint un petit
peu où la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est au fond il n'ya pas parce que on
sait nicolas sarkozy très
interventionniste est ce qu'il n'ya pas
aussi derrière tout cela
l'idée que le service public aujourd'hui
actuellement ne remplissait pas sa
fonction
bon mais que derrière la fonction qu'on
imagine pour le service public il ya
davantage de nostalgie ou d'idéalisation
des programmes d'hier encore que
personnellement je trouve que l'heure de
vérité était une formidable émission et
qui a et l'as cavel et l'asie mais
briller est ce qu'il y avait pas une
espèce que c'est plutôt que un regard
qui se tourne vers le voilà vers la
façon qu'il faut défricher n'est pas moi
je crois qu'il faut de ce défaut pour
tous les publics je pense que on doit
conserver par exemple un authentique
critères d'audience je pense qu'il faut
mesurer non seulement la quantité
d'audience mais la qualité sert à la
question combien étiez-vous pour voir
l'émission mais également qu'en
avez-vous retenu
je pense qu'on doit pouvoir écrire et
scénarisé de manière très moderne un
nouveau genre pour des émissions
politiques scientifiques ou autres ou
culturelles et que ça a toute sa place
dans le dans le service public mais pour
autant pas de méprise c'est pas le
président de la république le ministre
de la culture ou les députés qui vont
dire ce qui aura comme programmateur de
rendre c'est ridicule c'est pas notre
métier
personne d'ailleurs ne l'a jamais pensé
qu'il y ait dans un coin de tête pour
tous les jeunes générations nostalgie de
ce qu'on a pu voir quand on était petit
a coûté n'était pas si mauvaise que ça
la télé de quand on était petits la
seule chose c'est que personne n'imagine
de refaire la même demain parce que les
temps totalement changé et personne
n'imagine que c'est thierry la fronde
qu'on va mettre en prime time à 20h30
donc c'est réglé c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est quelle télé publique
demain on a regardé ce qui se faisait
ailleurs il ya des télés publiques en
europe formidable at et les talent days
that et les britanniques est intéressant
et bien nous on veut faire notre propre
modèle
je pense que ça peut être vraiment un
exemple pour l'europe la télé
britannique qui fait figure de modèle
parce qu elle est aussi très forte sur
l'information oui et puis également
qu'elle dérape pas mal sur le trajet
faut se dire les choses et nous on n'a
pas envie de jouer mais si je pensais
surtout à l'information pour
l'information du coup le fait de la
qualité de l'audience de deux du pr fait
que l'audience de la bbc va au delà de
ses frontières évidemment c'est parce
que la pièce parce qu'elle est
anglophone aussi oui ça peut aider dans
l'univers actuel juste à vous sur les
finances quand même parce que on voit
bien que les télévisions notamment les
télévisions privées sont entrés dans
aborde approche de la zone de turbulence
et avec la révolution d'internet du
moment où elles vont devoir changer de
modèle donc elle voit en voir deux
furieux problèmes de financement on se
dit bon le gouvernement les aides en
transférant de la recette
privé de publicitaires vers les chaînes
privées très bien sauf que ça ne peut
marcher que si vous garantissez ou si
l'état s'assure aussi la représentation
nationale s'assure que le service public
est vraiment car garantie dans sa
recette
alors là quelles garanties peut-on avoir
oui parce que sinon on a une télé
publique qui va être totalement alors
pour le coup sous la coupe des
contrôleurs de bercy je voudrais d'un
point absolument et 3 un contrôle
bureaucratique
bref il faut une garantie de l'ovaire et
son de la manière suivante je suis
quelqu'un qui a de la suite dans les
idées
et dans mon esprit il est hors de
question que mon travail s'arrête là
j'ai présidé cette commission pour
reprendre l'analogie avec les séries
américaines c'était la saison 1
oui pour la saison 2 ce sera la
rédaction du texte de loi et dans le cas
de la coproduction législative
je travaillerai avec christine albanel
et puis la saison 3 ce sera à l'automne
lorsque nous débattrons de ce texte et
que à titre personnel j'en serai le
rapporteur ce qui est très rare pour un
président de groupe afin de veiller à ce
que les engagements que nous avons pris
soient tenus
et puis ensuite je râle applications
mais dans mon esprit il est clair que
cela doit se faire en garantissant les
ressources et c'est tout l'intérêt
d'avoir introduit les fournisseurs
d'accès les téléphones mobiles car c'est
un secteur qui est très dynamique et qui
garantira une ressource pérenne et dîna
avec cette fameuse taxe qui serait de 0
9% de leur chiffre d'affaires
mais ce qu'on n'a pas vu moi ce qui
m'est apparue en tout cas en lisant les
comptes rendus de votre rapport est ce
qu'on avait tiré le président la
république c'est que il ya une recette
en effet avec cette cette nouvelle taxe
mais il ya aussi une demande assez
importante d'économie au service public
religieux et cette demande et donc ça ça
veut dire malgré ce très bien préciser
les choses
en fait nous avons prévu le financement
avec deux blocs et un premier bloc c'est
compensation de la perte de pub et un
deuxième bloc qui est financement du
développement
sur le blog compensation de la perte de
pub nous avons des gars des ressources
pérennes
la taxe fournisseurs d'accès l'attaqué
et téléphones mobiles la taxe sur les
télés privées correspondant au
supplément de pub récupérer et puis une
fois que vous avez cessé deux aimants là
vous couvrez la quasi totalité du
spectre s'ajoute à ça quelques recettes
annexes mais qui sont encore une fois
garantie
de l'autre côté le blog qui sert à
financer le développement c'est là
dessus que nous mettons les économies de
gestion de france télévisions c'est à
dire que france télévision lorsqu'elle
fera des gains de productivité pour
aller destiné aux réinvestissements et
en aucun cas à financer la perte de la
pub c'est comme pas comme vous savez à
l'armée autrefois pour pas être sûr
d'avoir les bonnes dotations budgétaires
on faisait tourner les moteurs de des
camions pour être sûr de pas voir une
dotation d'essence - dans l'année
d'après on est bien là on fait pas ça
puisqu'on intéresse france télévisions à
son investissement par les gains de
productivité réalisés et j'ajoute pour
être tout à fait complet jean marie
colombani que nous ajoutons à cela dans
le financement du développement
tout ce qui procède du dividende
numérique c'est à dire l'équivalent de
100 à 120 millions d'euros par an qui
seront en économie une fois qu'on sera
passer de l'analogique au numérique
si vous ajoutez à ça le développement la
filiale commerciale de france télé qui
elle aussi va apporter des ressources
supplémentaires
vous voyez que tout s'accumule et ça
fait entre 200 et 300 millions qui
permette qui seront uniquement dédiée à
l'investissement et au développement de
france télé en tout cas donc calendrier
madame albanel présente une un projet
donc en septembre
tout ça est bouclée d'ici la fin de
l'année mais le service public lui-même
va être dans une zone malgré tout
turbulences que quand on change la règle
du jeu à ce point tout ça n'est pas
n'est pas simple
pour que oui enfin en même temps les
choses maintenant sont bien avancer le
débat public est connu il n'ya plus de
surprise pour personne et maintenant ce
qu'il faut c'est mettre tout en oeuvre
alors remettre tout ça en oeuvre c'est
aussi un des unes des tâches du
président du groupe ump alors ça me
donne l'occasion de vous interroger
aussi sur l'état institutionnels des
choses non pas la réforme de la
constitution mais voilà un nouveau
président est élu il ya toujours un
triptyque président partie groupe
parlementaire je devrais même ajouté
gouvernement et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui les choses ne s'enclenche
pas comme elle devrait ou comme elle
pourrait l'être dans l'idéal peu importe
on voit bien qu'il ya des problèmes
on voit bien qu'il ya des problèmes à
l'ump où il ya un certain désordre des
nominations qui interviennent des
polémiques etc bref problèmes à l'ump
et puis à le groupe alors comment vous
situez-vous dans ce dans ce dans ce
fonctionnement et dysfonctionnements du
triangle du talent et celles qui
gouvernent la france aujourd'hui d'abord
votre lapsus était intéressant parce que
vous avez vous-même souvenez vous avez
omis de parler du gouvernement mais
c'est intéressant on voit bien ce que
cela veut dire
nicolas sarkozy que vous connaissez bien
que moi a toujours assumé clairement
qu'il était favorable à une lecture
présidentielle des cinquièmes de la vème
république et donc dans son esprit
l'idée c'est vraiment qu'il y ait une
centralisation du processus de décision
à son niveau celui la présidence de la
république
c'est à dire que le gouvernement ne fait
rien il fait beaucoup de choses du
gouvernement mais le processus de
décision
c'est le président il n'y a pas de
recours il n'y a pas de fusible n'y a
pas de deuxième niveau
c'est le président de la république et
ça c'est un élément très nouveau très
différents par exemple de la conception
qu'on avait monsieur chirac
deuxième élément du coup il ya un
affaissement du gouvernement et c'est
pour ça que vous l'avez omis parce que
c'est vrai que c'est plus tout à fait la
même chose qu'elle et quels sont les
pouvoirs importants
le parti naturellement mais vous avez
dit les difficultés qu'il connaît
aujourd'hui
quel parlement et pourquoi cette réforme
constitutionnelle que nous voulons voter
a du sens c'est parce qu'elle actes dans
les faits cette présidentialisation un
exécutif fort au niveau du président
comment d'un parlement fort et d'où
l'intérêt de partager lors du jour d'où
l'intérêt d'avoir des textes qui vont
nous venir depuis la commission
parlementaire et pas depuis le
gouvernement nous
l'intérêt enfin d'avoir un parlement qui
contrôle et évalue l'efficacité
gouvernementale qui existe dans tous les
pays d'europe sauf le nôtre c'est pour
ça que moi je suis très engagé dans
cette démarche de révision
constitutionnelle parce qu'en tant que
président du groupe majorité à moi mon
idéal est simple c'est comme notre
président du groupe
c'est pas une autorité hiérarchique avec
vos 320 députés faut pas imaginer ça
vous êtes chef de rien du tout vous êtes
là d'abord pour essayer d'imaginer que
le député de 2008 plus rien à voir avec
celui de 58 ne serait ce que parce qu'en
plus 85%
j'ai députés sont des réélus dire des
gens qui n'attendent pas demain d'être
nommé ministre parce qu'ils savent que
leur mission allait d'abord d'être
député qui connaissent parfaitement le
métier de député et qui veulent qu'ils
évoluent et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
pensé avec mes amis députés cette idée
de dire on va coproduire des réformes à
dire qu'on va pas attendre que ça arrive
tout ficelé et appuyer avec un regard
béat au sur le bouton oui sans regarder
notre idée désormais c'est con qu'on
produise en amont chaque réforme exemple
la loi de modernisation de l'économie
depuis trois mois avant son passage en
conseil des ministres avec christine
lagarde avec luc chatel chaque point a
été identifié 2 sauf que quand c'est
arrivé dans l'hémicycle y compris les
grandes surfaces tout avait été arbitré
traité et nous étions largement entendu
de même lorsque nous avions repris les
propositions du rapport attali
au début beaucoup de polémiques etc et
puis on a co produit et nous avons
repris beaucoup de choses comme par
exemple que regroupant département
région on nous disait vous n'êtes pas
capable on l'a fait alors moi ça m'amène
à des questions un petit peu plus
personnelle parce qu'on voit bien
l'intérêt que vous avez vous à
développer en effet j'allais dire la
sphère d'influencé du président du
groupe et donc la réforme
institutionnelle est évidemment de ce
point de vue là très importante parce
qu'au fond ce qu'il vous faut conjurer
c'est l'idée qu'on peut vous opposez on
connaît on dans le paysage politique
français
l'habitude en france c'est un président
est élu on pense au prochain et on pense
mais à préparer la prochaine échéance
donc on fait l'inventaire des
présidentiables qui peut en être qui
peut en être pas vous même vous êtes
déjà un petit peu catalogué dans ce qui
pourrait devenir présidentiable et c'est
donc votre problème c'est de conjurer au
fond le sort des précédents présidents
de groupe rpr ou autres qui n'ont pas
aux non j'ai pas ce souci pour une
raison simple
je vais vous dire une chose et si je
crois que c'est nicolas d'ailleurs lui
mais nicolas sarkozy qui m'avait confié
singes
avait dit il ya une règle d'or ne jamais
prendre le chemin le même chemin de son
prédécesseur lorsque l'on veut accéder à
une fonction essentielle ben ça tombe
bien président de groupe
ma connaissance aucun des présidents de
la république ne l'avait été auparavant
d'envoyer de ce point de vue il ya
absolument aucune connexion puis la
deuxième chose pour pas se tromper ce
qui compte c'est pas d'y arriver
même si c'est l'objectif c'est comment
est le vrai sujet de ce point de vue
c'est quoi moi personnellement je vous
dis les choses très sincèrement je suis
hantée comme d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amis
de ma génération par les querelles de
mes aînés nous n'avons rien oublié de ce
que furent ces bagarres si violents
qu'ils ont mis la droite par terre donc
moi je ne suis pas dans cet état
d'esprit
jamais je ne l'aurais ça je sais trop ce
que cela veut dire pour les français une
équipe qui gagne ensemble et donc moi je
n'ai qu'une qu'un objectif et c'est eux
je dirais un intérêt bien compris pour
le notre pays c'est que ça marche c'est
que les réformes de nicolas sarkozy
elles réussissent la seule chose que je
demande c'est que la mise en oeuvre de
ces réformes
elle soit fait avec l'assurance que les
députés sont totalement partie prenante
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas les
partenaires sociaux qui ont de la
possibilité de discuter du dialogue
social et par les députés il n'y a pas
le rock dont on peut parler à bruxelles
mais pas les députés français y'a pas
les grands le politique économique dont
on peut parler à bercy mais pas les
députés français n'ont rien de tout ça
moi ce que je veux c'est que semaine
après semaine mois après mois les
députés soient présents dans toute la
sphère du débat public et c'est ça mon
objectif
aucun autre et c'est à ça que je
travaille tous les jours en tout cas il
est clair que si la réforme
institutionnelle était adoptée ce sera
plus de pouvoir pour le parlement donc
plus de poids pour la majorité tout et
rien n'est donc plus dont vous serez
j'allais dire en meilleure position
enfin en même temps ge comme toujours
quand on est en responsabilité on sait
ne pas en abuser quand on est en
responsabilité on fait attention
vous savez je vais vous dire une chose
parfois il arrive que des amendements
soient votés en commission qui sur les
amendements excusez moi du mot débile
parce qu'on était 3 en séance parce
qu'on n'a pas fait attention parce qu'on
sait toute façon on corrigera dans
l'hémicycle et bien désormais ce type
d'acte irresponsable n'arrivera plus
désormais on sait que quand un
amendement sera adopté en commission
eh ben ils risquent fortement d'être
adoptée dans l'hémicycle donc il faudra
y faire attention
je pense moi beaucoup à l'idée qu'on
partage des responsabilités de manière
intéressante intelligente et moderne et
c'est tout
la force de la proposition nicolas
sarkozy ce qui attendait pas se tromper
cette réforme constitutionnelle à la
lettre près elle a été préparée
voulu par nicolas sarkozy candidat à la
présidentielle et moi je les ai soutenus
à fond depuis la première minute parce
que je pense tout en étant très attaché
à la vème république qu'elle peut
évoluer dans un sens très moderne et
c'est pour ça que je suis à fond pour
cette réforme
eh bien ce sera le mot de la fin merci
jean françois copé merci beaucoup pour
celles et ceux qui voudraient retrouver
le contenu de cette émission rendez vous
également sur publicsenat.fr
vous souhaitez réagir à cette émission
poser des questions débattre regardez en
accès gratuit et illimité la chaîne en
temps réel où les programmes en vod
rendez vous sur www.publicsenat.fr
et tout de suite
parlons blog le meilleur du web avec
caroline deschamps